it's so interesting that we're doing the
interview today but something very
unique happened today today's the first
time a commercial plane
flew from israel and landed in uae
something that hasn't happened in 20
years and jared kushner
was on that flight you and i we know
this the abraham accord
you know a big deal that took place
drunk during the
uh trump administration something that
people thought was impossible
why is that such a big deal to some
people that don't know a lot about this
don't follow the topic
why is that such a big deal well that
that's unprecedented i mean that has
never happened in the history of
israel i mean the last few years things
are happening i mean
even relations with saudi arabia on
unimaginable in past years i mean they
wouldn't have a jewish person
from israel there ever uh these were
nations that hated israel ward against
israel
and now they're making peace you know up
kind of partly because of what's
happening in iran and to
to ally together so it's amazing and and
trump has had a part in it as well
you know so it absolutely unprecedented
and there may be
other arab nations that join in so we're
watching something
that nobody has ever seen from the
beginning of the birth of israel so who
does that benefit by the way so
if i'm living in america and i see this
on the news and they show this oh it's
such a big deal it's never happened it's
unprecedented
and i don't follow these topics i know
nothing about the history how does it
benefit me as an american
well you know if if israel is is making
peace
with its neighbors that benefits really
everybody as far as they are
it also benefits you know the fact and
also actually it does benefit america
because
um you know when there's when there's
warfare there it benefits a lot of times
enemies of america
um but and on top of the fact you listen
when it you know the bible says
when israel is blessed you know the
world is blessed so it's got to be a
good that that part's gonna be a good
thing not
not that we think there's gonna that
means there's gonna be peace
uh all the area we know we know more
things about the bible says very clear
things about it
but it's it's an amazing thing um and
again unprecedented so
so more a world peace type of a benefit
to the world where less conflict means
you know more advancement is that kind
of the way to look at it well well it
means that yeah well it actually it
actually marginalizes
terrorism you know because i mean this
this is you know i mean because the more
you do this the more
funding for terrorism is is taking out
elite now i'm not talking about iran or
those but in the arab world
so for the listen for the arab world
it's a great thing because again and
there's something that goes back four
thousand years
called we've talked with abraham accord
the abrahamic covenant says you bless
israel
you're going to be blessed and then the
other part is also with the embassy i
mean
you you you hear the story about you
know the embassy in israel was moved
from tel aviv to jerusalem by
president trump in 2019 and we keep
hearing about this again
to the average executive business owner
ceo you know person that's running their
own company
you hear this why is this also a big
deal that this is happening during trump
these are two different items that are
taking place
why is it such a big deal to go from tel
aviv to jerusalem well there has there
has never been
in all the history of israel there has
never been any major power that has
recognized jerusalem in fact to find to
find any parallel you have to go back
to ancient times even to the days of
king
cyrus in persia you know because that
the last time you had a major
a major uh leader world leader
recognizing jerusalem
that's persia that that goes back in the
bible so this was major
and you know the bible speaks about in
in israel that jerusalem
is going to be the center of conflict
well that's part of it but also that
that nations which says nations will try
to move jerusalem like the status well
that's part of it but also it says that
israel will rebuild that temple so
all these things play a part in that and
trump i mean
i wrote a book where i you know this is
the book that just came out but the last
book i did
called the oracle goes into the
mysteries behind all these things and
the thing is that
that trump you know one of his one of
the things that he follows i mean
in in that we have we and we can go
wherever you want but in the paradigm he
follows a man there's a
pattern a man called jehu but but that's
for america and there's a lot to it
but for uh for israel he said he's
osiris you know which is the persian
king who recognized jerusalem
but cyrus you know it's amazing because
when you look at trump
and you look at the time when the first
resolution
concerning israel and jerusalem was
voted on by the u.n
this is in 1940 1947 on the hebrew
calendar and you you the bible says
70 years but it talks about a 70-year
period
it says after 70 years cyrus issued this
thing well if you take that date
and you go on the hebrew calendar to 70
years
and and it says after so the day after
it's the exact
date that trump issued the jerusalem
declaration
exact day and is that what you wrote
about in the book paradigm in 2017
that's in the oracle that's in the
oracle the authors of the mysteries of
israel the mystery i mean amazing stuff
that's happening and trump
is in there the paradigm is speaking it
speaks about the
the the uh jehu jezebel and all these
people in america that has to do with it
with america
and trump and all this stuff that's
happening